par la cie tel match fabien supérieur
ouais sur parole non commencés choses
étaient bien c'était beau si puissant
c'était puissant alors moi je vais
lancer un tournoi pour ce soir parce que
là c'est difficile pour nous de jouer
parce qu'on a on a fait les cinq heures
de direct et tout donc c'est difficile
de faire une longue session mais mais je
vais lancer un tournoi et en fait on va
faire un tournoi de 960 si vous le jour
tu veux pas je joue peu et on va lancer
à 20h30 35 comme 120 peut discuter sur
le chat donc je lance et puis après je
voulais le chat et on va mettre en cinq
minutes et on va mettre six rondes comme
ça ça fait une heure c'est bien très
bien aujourd'hui 20h35 six rondes c'est
parti c'est parti il est la vitrine 960
adresse que j'ai bien mise échec 960 ou
pas j'aurais dû boucher pas comment
vérifier non je vais le relancer attends
je vais refaire
attends je refais on sait jamais ce que
je me rappelle plus si j'ai fait ou pas
et enfin j'arrive pas à voir donc attend
donc club tournament échec 963 j'avais
pas fait heureusement waouh ou fch
bazire est un objet diouf aux échecs en
fait ça a été très pénible
donc aujourd'hui cadence est toujours
cinq minutes c'est toujours aujourd'hui
c'est sûr 20h35 et sa tour être six
rondes cinq minutes way 5 + 0 machin
aujourd'hui 20h35 six rondes 1960 à
chaque 960 va livrer échec
enfin nous on appelle ça les vrais
échecs après il peut y avoir des
représentants défaut échec qui peut
appeler ça un échec 960 donc on préfère
tu as donné le nom officieux du truc en
fait ouais mec là bas c'est quand même
mieux
attends je vais récupérer les tchats bam
c'est vraiment un match d'anthologie
qu'on a suivi la fab aujourd'hui c'était
trop beau c'était c'était beaucoup trop
beau attends je vais récupérer sur une
chaise points comme tv avait su comment
il se fait ce point comme tv au mans il
ya des langages différents sur le tweak
je ne sais pas je ne sais pas non si on
est là on est là donc on va le tournoi
plus tournant mais je l'affiché à
l'écran vous êtes déjà 2 alors est-ce
qu'il ya toi dans les deux ou pas non
non juste bon constructeur encore
inscrits n'ont donc on ne s'est pas tu
feras ou pas pour le moment à fortiori
c'est pas sûr c'est parce que je réponde
aux ne joue pas que je vous dise
je suis l'agent qui je le vois pas mais
il y en a c'est sûr qu'il y aurait ce
que vous participez au club bitstream
alors ces gens là même question en fait
qu'on se pose seins sans arrêt des gens
qui ne voient pas est ce que vous êtes
dans le dans le club lice rim ce que tu
n'es tu pas dans complices rim c'est pas
bon donc une nouvelle fois je vais
expliquer femme je fais de la guitare
sur le petit score
je fais d'ailleurs je suis pédagogue les
fils d'or qui réside à paarl avait parlé
lui jeudi des sondes son petit message
sur le sur le switch
moi j'ai envie de lui dire bravo merci
darryl f
après on our suivre maintenant de nous
supporter huit heures dans une journée
fantastique c'est surtout un exploit
pour toi tu réussis à me supporter huit
heures après les autres bon je ne vois
pas comment je vais vers le club
non je sais pas comment tu fais
je sais pas où tu as lu ce message là
moi je ne vois rien mais bonjour tout
cas j'ai emilie 1 du club 2 partout pour
que les gens puissent a fortiori un j'ai
envie de dire s'inscrire et on voit
qu'il ya trois inscrits alors c'est
qu'ils allaient qui s'équipent mariama
tafer al grade et sheth 30 54
ça va venir petit à petit de quel droit
ils se sont inscrits de quel droit la
fille d'annie merci fap quoi
d'ici une petite tête ne sais pas d'où
qui a je les vois enfin là on est ok on
parle plus sur discorde sur le chat
twitch que sinon je supporte jusqu au
bout du monde
bravo ça c'est bien l'enjeu john grigg
discorde qui grandit en d'ailleurs parce
que bientôt enfin je ne sais pas ce que
c'est pas le premier chat des chaque
français au final certaines questions
chantante et bientôt une grande
communauté comme l'était bitstream ils
sont là ils sont partout vous font chier
le monde coiffant physiciens se frotta
stick et avec deux gourous taguine tête
de gourou je sais pas ce que fera jaguar
est un groupe en tête à madrid a rasé la
barbe les costumes boxer est-ce que
royal qui je ne trouve pas le temps est
ce que tu es inscrit au club bitstream
c'est un peu la question que en train de
me poser et qu'on est tous en droit de
se poser
antibes et regagne are you going to play
oui oui à organizing de tournament
if you want to participate wifi au but i
want to play du tournoi à beaulieu 15 as
seen in den driessche winches club
adhérent de playzone en deux en deux
couleurs le tournoi les fioritures
member of the blue dream club
ayew et veulent tous doublettes etc
5ce et caresse dans le sens du poil
mais je pense qu'ils ont compris qu'ils
sont ni fous dit stream ça parle anglais
à la chaîne en anglais d'un sac et une
mylène une de mes vidéos qui a pas mal
de succès d'ailleurs sur la chaîne en
anglais mais 10 conseils pour bien gelée
finale deux tours et les mecs adore
quand ils sont là inscrit ce que tu peux
refaire des vidéos comme ça s'il te
plaît non les mecs bitstream sauve nous
en prenons françois dans cette
trouvaille qui a rejoint le club il voit
toujours pas le tournoi ben regarde un
peu sur mon surnom screen
normalement c'est en haut à droite dans
tournoi fait un petit refresh je sais
pas batwa bas ils sont déjà 5 à ninja 31
160 d ici mais là le 960 je pense que ça
va chauffer tout le monde je pense que
tout le monde est chaud patate tient
dernier jay russell veulent mais parce
qu'autrement effectivement saint
françois qui sait vous lisez les
commentaires et où on lit les
commentaires
tu sais quelle quelle vidéo gervis a pas
longtemps la de cyprien je me suis
remarié je parle pas trop stressé
pologne le clash des gitans je l'avais
montré ça ou pas italien je fais ou el
taller lopes qui bat de partout c'est
fantastique c'est qui est le buzz zani
ça va et cd lopez il faut absolument que
tu regardes à des que bâchée par regard
maintenant si tu en voilà bah après mais
c'est fantastique
je pense qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui
connaissent dans les chat mais elle est
fantastique cette vidéo cd l'eau presque
il faut se taper dessus tout cas prête
en un troisième absolument rien à voir
qui fait une vidéo aussi produire j'ai
eu que les autres lots presse voulait
taper dessus mais plus aussi on est des
cons le même nom de famille on va aller
nous aussi on veut cet appareil vous
faire une croix n'a en fait voilà on est
combien on est pour le moment on est 5
c'est un peu léger mais il reste 26
minutes à jouer au chat sur le live pour
les 56 faiblard
c'est bien pour essayer c'est un tournoi
des échecs 960 exactement le charpentier
7 chacha keyyo les warriors vous
n'arrêtez jamais non mais on est
toujours là quoi tout en tout 30
ok mais fatigué quand même non en fait
je suis au taquet en fait non bon ben ce
soit en forme moi je suis fatigué le nom
tu n'as pas le droit c'est interdit
c'est interdit c'est pas homologué très
attention c'est comme le dress code
c'est parce mousse mais du coup demain
après demain tu es en pls que c'est sur
cette analyse et j'ai toujours que tu
espères une petite nuit demain entre
rebelles et civils
[Rires]
j'espère qu'on va faire une petit nul 15
coups mais ça se peut que ce soit une
petite ville en fête demain message ou
demandez pas eu de recours mais bien sûr
ça joue bien ce que je pensais c'est un
site qui est venu te dire ah ils
voulaient venir se faire de la pub sur
notre chat écrire que j'avais jours de
repos demain en fait non vidéo échec tu
disais vidéo et chaque fois comme tu
écris mais le chat non mes vidéos et
chacun toujours justes presque alors ça
reprendra qu'il ya eu pas mal de vidéos
de kevin avec ou sans fabien à y compris
ses quatre matches quand la mission du
juge sur youtube merci les gars pour
mettre les vidéos sur maxime par exemple
c'est très instructif
merci saint françois n'oublie pas de ta
bonne et de partout
la vraie plaie qu'est ce qui je suis
débile je crois je n'arrive vraiment à
trophées ont confirmé en confiance
si mam au quai s'étaient pas inscrits au
truc
tiens un bug mais en fait une fois une
fois que tu es là en admettant à temps
j'essaye de une fois que tu es là en
fait sur la plaie eason faut que tu
ailles là tu vas dans tournoi tournois à
venir donc cup coming à venir et la
table isri de 960 et c'est là qu'il faut
que tu cliques une fois que tu cliques
là tu vas te retrouver sur 7 sur cette
adresse et tu vas avoir battu voire
tonte regret ya déjà six personnes qui
jouent je sais pas comment mieux
t'expliquer en fait je sais pas si je
peux mieux expliquer en fait face en
voisin qui va s'abonner qui n'étaient
pas bonnes et rem abonne toi attend là
bas
j'écris ici aussi tu écris sur des
tchats écrite par tous dont moi même on
vous présente le baume par quoi on fait
pour être dans le club pour être dans le
club il faut il faut cliquer sur fin il
faut aller dans participer rejoindre
participer au club lice rime donc tu as
le lien sur twitter
pardon on dirait que les gens ne voient
rien valises écrivent tout ivoirien mais
est ce qu'ils sont dans le club
bon je ne connais pas tous font comme si
je veux quelque chose a en fait faut que
tu ailles dans le club et puis après que
tu ailles sur le truc de live en fait ça
il faut que tu comprennes c'est qu'une
fois que vous êtes dans le club vous
participez au club la presse et dans le
match ben eager en diable ce que je fais
donc j'ai l'esprit double double 14
points comme j'arrive je me login sur le
bim si on joue dans le registre et sinon
vous tapez ok je suis login et très bien
à ce moment là parce que je vais dans
jouer jouer échec en direct donc là ça
nous la page après genève tournoi en
haut à droite même si tonglet hockey et
et puis maintenant moi je cherche
d'extraits 1966 et là dans 22 minutes je
le vois
gérald et si j'habite sur participer je
joue et sinon je joue pas peu importe je
sais pas si je joue donc toi tu trouves
groupe
je les trouvais je m'inscris à ce jeu
mais en fait c'est sûr après faut aller
sur 13 points comme slash live une fois
que vous êtes dans le club et après vous
allez trouver le tournoi mais je sais
pas pourquoi c'est toujours si difficile
de trouver les trouver sur trois points
comme par le livre à cette salle est
plus sûr mais c'est vrai il faut une
voiture et faire la manif à la même
place cc c'est simple après tu as raison
tu fais comme live et puis tu vas tu vas
voir le tournoi dans tournant n'y a pas
de lien direct pour le tournoi mais je
vous sens je vous sens en pls en fait
avec les tournois à are you qui dit
allez vas-y joue libye et les shows are
your own le creux que le cac
si je peux le dire je préfère perdre
s'il faut je joue lorsqu'on a un père ou
quoi pourquoi pas on est onze là on est
bon ça va je crois je crois que la manip
lâche je commence bon ben ok les gars
vous ayez inscrits au club alors je sais
pas et une fois que vous l'êtes c'est
très simple vous allez sur jouer dès le
chantre échec en direct chez qu'en
différé plein de trucs nouvel échec en
dialecte à bien sa charge le truc
glauque vous trouver des adversaires
quand je vais maintenant tous à m'lasse
normand c'est au tour du ctif l'objectif
c'est de jouer le tournoi pourrait donc
tourner et vous trouvé le truc bitstream
960 et puis voilà je pense que si je
pense que ça trouble en tout cas si noah
le fils a trouvé donc pouces bleus pour
ce vol
mais bon allez c'est ce que sur discorde
n'y a pas d'autres encore une façon
quand on est on ça va enfin une fois
qu'on a passé les 10 tu vois on est on
est sorti de la zone natura de la zone
critique voilà dix joueurs déjà ces
taxes jardiner sans attendre homologué
ouais c'est homologué la seconde après
ce que les gens sont assez bien habillée
pour le jeu reste parce que dress code
distrib en moi chaussettes
est ce que ça marche un sandales
chaussettes ou chaussettes tout court
cette dangereuse parce que sandales
chaussettes c'est pas c'est pas
homologué tu n'as pas loin ça ça ne
marche pas peux tu donner le lien vers
10 cordes bien sûr je deviens le lien
vers discorde vicitmes qui veut
rejoindre le discorde et il a bien
raison besim il a bien raison
voilà vous prélève sa être l'équipe bis
rim est partout tout le temps hier tu
faisais la master class dont cours
collectifs la boum
tu arrives mvl gris tubes boom le
tournoi temps plus quoi ils y
jetteraient chemise pour le cours
collectifs hier ça va trop bien vivre
peut-être bien m'habiller
elle t'a fait si si si je ne m'abuse a
fait un petit passage sur la tête a été
plus qu'un participantes avaient été
quelque part acteurs si je ne m'abuse en
bref cet imbécile qui nous a rejoint sur
le discorde à 34 personnes un nouveau
bon non plus les de luxe à six par
balles et en fait je peux peut-être
mettre un lien vers le vers le live
tweet j'en fais ça et qu'on ne fait
jamais ça parce qu'en fait c'étaient des
gens sur le discorde tu vois qu'ils
veulent
on est tous une option ouverte est
arrivé sur le score la discorde c'est
pas mal hein j'aime bien là on est 38 40
ainsi que dix corps mais partout ti
blitz trim sur discorde m 2 dans la team
psg français je voulais être acteur sans
rêves d'enfants et des mois pour
rejoindre le tournoi alors on va alors
ouais faut qu'ils soient devant le
blitzkrieg nos villages sans voix le 1er
mai un club lille stream up et ensuite
dans le chai ce dans trois points comme
slash live dans le jeu en direct je
pense que snow white plains peut t'aider
peut-être c'est un peu ça mais on
grandit un petit à petit désolé pour les
gens qui regardent peut-être le live à
qui va avoir un peu d'autres choses mais
bon il faut petit à petit qu'on apprenne
à le faire mais plus on est fous plus on
rit
tyson 000 euros qui n'ai jamais eu ma
plus belle paire de crocs pour ce
tournoi de gala aya spirou qui lit
comment participer au tournant alors
spirou il faut que tu fasses tu
participes aucune blitz frime et après
que tu ailles dans 13 points comme slash
live donc d'enjeux en direct que tu peux
voir là sur mon écran échec en direct je
vais garder cliquez dessus et puis après
en haut à droite tu auras les tournois a
fortiori alors françois explique eileen
qu'est ce que le tournoi que tu
organises a de particulier ben c'est un
peu le jeu un tournoi bitstream
donc si tu veux bon celui qui le gagne -
la graine tourabi stream si tu veux
c'est gros c'est voilà dans un palmarès
si tu veux bon matin tandis qu'ils ont
gagné bon les candidats championnat du
monde tous ah bon c'est pas mal champion
d'europe champion de france machin mais
tu as la ligne de palmarès j'ai gagné
1,3 à vitry donc c'est un peu ça chauffe
qui le rend si spécial le cluster
peut-être un abonnement premium je sais
pas quoi on sait pas on s'est passé en
garde à vue et ou pas ce truc là une
époque ça marche mais de rappeler les
règles dures à carreaux et en échec 960
pour roque et vous verrez un peu sûr
votre position
si vous approchez droits de vote retour
ça
fera un grand roque en petit rock il
faudra le sentier efforts seront dix
bombes du rock comme si tu raques aux
échecs leur avance et un la tour en d1
où orange est un atout important
position peut-être faire moi une partie
960 essaie de mettre quelqu'un en pls
n'ont rien indiqué dans le club donc si
tu es dans le club pour voir si le
tournoi il faut que tu allais sur bon
côté login et tu attends je fais échec
en direct donc on a hâte ap
tarek un deuxième palier là en haut à
droite un petit truc qui fait pour moi
non mais c'est un peu d'énigmes
j'imagine joueur du grenier qui essayent
de s'inscrire au tournoi qu est ce que c
est la hitbox et du jeu on dira est allé
shit et sept ou huit boxes quoi alors
deuxième niveau x lion tournoi et puis
la tenue de tournois et celui-là
s'appelle 970 strihou visserie 1966 plus
on reconnaît le petit cheval symbole
meanstream je vois même le bien et le
mal
j'irai même le bit silvestri un geste
vraiment je n'avais jamais remarqué un
peu sérieux voilà donc mon lit je le
vois mais tu participes à un truc dont
tu comprends mais plutôt aux folles sur
ce vol de merde
aujourd'hui je trouve que ça représente
tu vois ça représente le bien et le mal
classé comme les échecs tout est relatif
quoi je ne voyais que le cheval bleu
depuis dix ans c'est fantastique on
devrait faire taire les musées qui
comprend le sait faire une vidéo comme
ça puis ta clique fabien les business
comprend le loroux blitz mais je pense
que très peu de monde malgré cela on va
demander aux gens vous avez compris ou
pas non mais genre jeu comme par winamax
de sites
de pari en ligne bah je sais pas quoi
pour winamax en fait j'ai même pas
cherché à détailler gagne un maximum à
winamax a jamais le winamax et kiloutou
tu t'es jamais digéré kiloutou pas
toujours juste genre un truc comme
kirikou pendant 26 ans fin à ces écrits
kiloo 8 et une section valider ses fins
qui loue tout contrat ou ouais je sais
pas je n'aime pas qu'ils louaient en
photo avec medion rapport à ploeren
d'accord alors leur pression mais
pourquoi pas d'une souveraineté at il
dit que le fou flomo carrefour saint
c'est ouais je sais peut-être donc pas
moi tout ça vous regarde pas c'est
bizarre mais pour le logo busserine que
vous aviez compris ou pas que c'était de
chevaux le ying et le yang
ou disons plutôt une sorte de s'en aller
dans l'onglet tournois et après aller ce
qui arrive au deuxième mali et là
attention ce qui est fou c'est déjà ça
adjust et bien peut-être alors là c'est
déjà c'est bien sûr le truc tournoi
battus à dessus et puis états unis ce
tournoi et d'entendre industrie 1960
donc été deux chevaux du coup mon action
de l'avant explique américaine bleus
maintenant il ya un lien glande cliquer
dessus
voilà et puis normalement tu as un petit
truc en mots la fin par là en jaune
orange étudie peut participer
ninja n'avait pas compris non plus n'est
pas le seul mais j'ai l'impression que
c'était très physique a et deux shows en
fait un truc of a down ans et je le vois
et entends tu sens le yin et le yang pas
à une mise assez bizarre ces deux trucs
blanc bleu dans le blanc l'usap avait
quoi quelque part avec ton talent malgré
un mal gommer
pop rock c'est pour nous c'est génial là
même qui avait pas eu personne chance
était le seul n'était pas dans mon truc
là c'est quoi ce tournoi là c'est le
monde tourmalet c'est génial qu'est ce
que c'est que ça et on est 18 ans
maintient temps de ça peut-être je te
renvoie non il ya peut-être atteint le
deuxième palier mais les parties à
contresens
il m'a donné au niveau -1 quoi remonter
et éveiller tous raté les deux chevaux
fut stérile mais ils ressortent pas très
bien que le cheval peut peut-être parce
qu'il est dans un carré blanc autour de
la saxe qui avait compris mais terrien
le plus noir tête dans le truck 3d là
quand tu as le bliss rim python de
soirée le choix de tête mais attends je
me referais lui de vous revoir ta spirou
qui dit ok c'est dur du match entre
entre le tournoi entre le tournoi qui
durera participer logo du truc est
complètement incompréhensible on en pls
les mecs là tu en sais quoi nous avons
la lie à nouveau 3 déclaré
c'est ainsi qu'avec faut pas faire trop
compliqué que nous alors je comprends
pas moi j'ai un truc original c'est très
heureux en fait attention à l'ag logo 3d
qui va renier ou bas ça qu'on voit
beaucoup mieux que votre capture écran
je vais me mettre dans le discours à
dallas les pauvres américains d'être là
ils doivent pas comprendre foudre notre
couple quoi ils peuvent américain et
enveloppes plaisir les français il se
marre gisèle beaucoup plus prompt que
les streamer américain qu'on a
d'habitude surtout les deux là ils
doivent se dire c'est les deux là ils
ont l'air complètement au dessus
pas une fois que tu as rejoint le droit
d'en lire ou c'est bon alors on les voit
bien quoi regarder comme ça tout est
inversé comme ça autour il est très beau
j'aime bien le district arrive sur la
gueule et des garages
j'aurais peut-être que rajouter
d'ailleurs ça pourrait le faire c'est
dans le sourire a ajouté une piste audio
beats prime time sur la gueule tu
t'écartes pensera le club très très
content car je vais acheter un micro h à
19 h un pur jeu prend sa part les russes
moi je suis fatigué quand je commence à
aller à dire les chiffres en russe alors
est ce que tu vas apprendre à compter
jusqu'à dix ans rue cela pendant qu'on
attend moi non
tant pis on va doubler peut-être contre
le snob
on essaiera en cartes donc des partages
dimanche
ouais enfin bon je pense que ce sera
réglé d'ici l'homme
en fait ce sont bien deux massacres en
fait j'aime bien le foot tu vois bout
enfin tu as a service volée de max
2 0 je vois bien tu vas tu es servir
volé tué à l'extérieur
montady la fouille et remet la balle est
là dans le contre-pied 2,8 leur pays
pose la volée dans le contre-pied
françois qui voit j'étais pas dans le
club je n'ai pas le tournoi tu passes
les paliers tout seul bravo enfin en
tout cas ya vingt-deux personnes qui ont
réussi à rentrer dans le tournoi
non mais c'est la première fois que
c'est dur on rigole un peu mais c'est la
première fois c'est comme tout la
première fois c'est pas c'est jamais
évident alors oui charlie nick et kevin
tu as écris un ton article sur ce point
comme sur les parties d'aujourd'hui mais
j'ai pas je n'ai pas finalisé mais
presque oui parce que c'était fragile je
passais plus de passer déjà deux heures
dessus en train de décrire d'annoter les
parties de réaliser les variantes et
tout mais non ce soir je le mettrais je
compte sur le chat discorde pour la
correction de ce que j'ai juste plus
vieux en fait après je vois plus en fait
au gras moins bon mais je progresse de
jeu et autant vous bien winky je trouve
pas le tournoi omaha de le cacher quoi
surprendre
en fait ok je pense qu'on va faire un
tuto ça se retourne contre en fin de
vidéo à jour mais cette vidéo on
hésitait encore c'est quoi ces mots
c'est une merde c'est en fait inscrire
des mots tournoi on va plus dans leurs
autoroutes 35 matin mater faire il 28 7
minutes en coréen est bon le truc c'est
que pour faire ces vidéos pour pour
faire ces vidéos faites sur un jour et
faire des vidéos drôles mais ça m'a
demandé beaucoup de montage et tout va
faire ces trucs là je veux vraiment
faire un truc bien avec dargaud bord qui
va arriver aujourd'hui d'argile regarder
tutoriel vous faire la voix de dark
vador et où tu vas enfin je suis comme
ces radars gros bords
tu fais bien je récupérerai peut-être
ton bruit la base est super c'est pas
mal je suis toi btk sa monnaie notre art
gros porc ce sera ce à quoi je suis ton
père tu es cas est complètement
n'importe quoi et il fait pas et vous
quoi il est juste car et havlat sk
palpatine derrière bon du coup sûr
gradés pas trop triste ben j'ai écrit ma
part répondu un boss déjà non mais moi
je pense que l'avs pour le pen l'a dit
c'est vraiment qui sait de quel droit
ces des amis il doit dire iron duke
regarde litres ils se foutent de ta
gueule quoi céder à miss a beat stream
non mais je pense qu'il a assez déçu
mais j'ai pas s'il passera peut-être y
passera sur la chaîne pour pour dire
quelque chose
enfin pour mettre tout le monde en pls
mais j'ai remarqué que la voix de vlad
que j'ai fait sur le téléphone ça fait
rire personne tout à l'heure dans live
en fait j'ai pas passé j ai connaissent
pas non ils connaissent pas je constate
chez pas alors que c'était hyper drôle
non bah oui si tu connais pas les
références
ouais regardez votre vidéo chat ces gens
qui ont là je vois qu'il est tourné en
inde autre façon moi je me rappelle
qu'en janvier tout ça on quatre tournois
deep au prix il y une centaine de points
d'eau à perdre mais les gobelins à huy
où la junte ou juan 960 sans regarder
les mecs je vais faire un grand roque
donc je vais virer mais pièces-là petit
à petit je vais faire un grand comme ça
vous allez voir comment ça marche
donc on s'en fiche de la partie 1 qu'on
perde ou qu'on gagne ça n'a aucune
importance moi ce que je veux faire
c'est un grand roque donc je vais
dégager les pièces un maximum et en face
de la partie je ferai le grand roque
maintenant tout tu peux pas voir mais
bon on fait juste n'arrivera pas mais
voilà jean roch
donc en fait je suis allé vers vers ma
tour et ça m'a fait rocqué comme un roc
normal et on l'apprend compte une
appartient lui peut faire petit rock en
allant vers sa tour ça va ramener la
toux
en f1 voilà exactement il a fait petit
rock j'espère que vous avez compris ce
qu'on veut pas faire beaucoup plus pour
la peine c'était important ce petit truc
là je suis complètement mal parce que
j'ai faim j'ai tout fait pour vous
montrer comment rock et donc bah en fait
est juste jouer en tant que genre doris
vous savez quel maroc et tout ça mais
bon là on est super mal mais juste
complètement foutue bien mais bon vous a
appris à rockets
comme on avait ça a l'air d'être un
génie en phase donc j'ai encore grands
espoirs
même si la position du rallye j'ai monté
mon roi dans l'esprit y en a quatre
otages
jamais mon pions domine son cavalier on
essaye de jouer vite je vois la salle
the beast qui ne vit de façon ça sert à
rien de rock et voilà l'attitude de sem
moi je vais donc le roi à la volée
c'est un espèce de stefan edberg le roi
je le monte à fond plat genre à me faire
une montée de folie là c'est une montée
à la volée c'est fantastique car à 3 3
boules droit qui monte c'est fantastique
la marche entre un jouet boubée 5 je
cache mon rang à quatre ça me saoule de
vaincre on tarde pas à l'abattoir un jeu
sur facebook je vois un truc de suzanne
polgar il écrire wayne game matters et
fait une capture écran de la position
donc une veltins get you can tell la
dernière ronde
quand il a acheté trois années noires
dont j'ai trois fiefs de 0 à 100 en
relatif mais décrit une disposition
bande ka bla bla bla et tout bendern
riesling 64 h 4 12 points
d'interrogation avant la très grave
question les outils de notre joueur
which in the beach hockey nord américain
ce week end un grec dans mes j'arrache 4
kg face à roddick maquis mais qui sait
déjà que tu joues joujou sacre
continental pendule et comprend pourquoi
h3c mieux à steinen deux heures explique
on va voir quand le tournage 3 est mieux
quand un ch 4 qu'est ce que tu as fait
et je sais mais bon c'est à mes pieds
mais juste c'est trop simple que c'est
ça c'est pas bien joué parce je traîne
deezer a quand même d'un bras dans cette
nation ça me saoule en fait de leur
centre mais bon c'est souvent ça
non mais oh qu'est ce tu viennes pageard
je sais pas le plan du sénat ok mais
avec deux secondes à la pendule
ok tu peux tu peux publier ça toi mais
là c'est quoi ça
très facile de faire le manach les ordis
et puissant placions alors qu'en plus tu
en sais absolument rien le studio du
tournage est en train de descendre la
magnanerie atrocités facebook la soul
pop art sont ya trop de gens qui
commentent avec les hardis qui se
rendent pas compte comme la sécher leurs
six autres jeunes boyard connaît bien de
savoir que le calme toi à toi lui dit
elle quand tu vois pas gagner cette
région
même avec deux heures à la pendule
compte donc mais moi non plus pas venir
je me perds dire ça parce que je sais
que moi non plus j'aurais pas compris
h34 défiance et même la religion ça je
sais que l'empattement pourquoi
peut-être un courage quatre chèques
intervenir avant les banques et les
coordinateurs ask barracuda veulent base
tu allais ou la bh4 être exact mais
sinon j'essaye de faire il son cavalier
mais j'y arrive pas en fait c'est parti
le temps d'un mois je finis ma partie
des bills alors je compatis mort ou le
premier donc ne suis pas un suisse coutu
ingénieurs suivre après moi je finis ma
partie et moi je suis pas aller choper
le cavale en fait j'essaie de le faire
tomber en fait un ancien autre très
bonne stratégie
un succès en train de porter ses fruits
la mecque en pls alors je vais me matter
en fait non je le mat pas mais je le
domine
je fais n'importe quoi à nouveau sa ré
suffire ce qu'il est mal autant ok moi
j'ai gagné maintenant je suis 2661 965
attention dégager tous alors moi je
regrette à partie du contre team roues
ce que c'est tout ça même qu'ils
n'avaient qu'à y être à la place de
grille tout cas et ça l'a été à la place
de youtube aurait pu nous montrer son
excellente technique en finale très
dommage en fait un mail à quai c'est
juste grotesque
je comprends qu'on passe normalement
elle doit elle forme des joueurs machin
non affecté là tu es pas content de dire
oui ou leur garde est crétin c'est
original grâce à la course et c'est un
truc mais en fait j'ai même pas pourquoi
ils font ça parce que ça arrive souvent
en fait kiffer à ce genre d'idiotie qui
raconte ce genre d'idiotie en fait notre
sèchement pas été choqué choquée moi je
suis non mais des gens qui souffrent ces
chèques ont les dents ne portent pas ou
qu'ils comprennent pas à quoi bon des
grands maîtres tête à tête et je dis tu
vas tu comprends copain elle a fait des
conneries dans sa vie pas et il a passé
des heures avec vos télés finale norman
qu'on fasse ça va quoi non mais enfin je
suis 100% d'accord avec toi il ya trop
de mais c'est vrai que ça vous c'est
comme ça que karlsson et péter un câble
avec le not so smooth en fait bah oui
parce que vraiment c'est n'importe quoi
fatale est à ses yeux tourner
l'ordinateur et explique à tout le monde
la life comme si c'était je sais pas moi
génie
dans cette série ce tour nous là ça va
être serré ce tournoi pour le moment il
ya bébé rasta qui est leader du tournoi
il s'est fait un petit j'ai déjà gagné
la première non ils étaient exempts en
fait eux n'ont même pas dans 28 joueurs
prend le large
non non il a gagné il a battu siredey
ben alors je sais pas comment il a fait
mais regagner rapidement et vous en 960
tu vois des trucs très bizarre envie de
partir on a tous la même position
bon on se trompe qu'elle jette un coup
d'oeil bon maintenant voici
non ces positions différentes et
beaucoup plus drôle d'air non non mais
ça permet puisque chelsea 3 1 abstention
tout a qu'une position en fait qui est
tout le temps jouer un mélange réserve
pas non logique
pourquoi pas tous besoin chaque ronde
non mais c'est pas mal le fait dans un 3
e du sourou la même position dans le
sens où tu as tu peux te préparer
progresser au fil des parties ce peut
être marrant quoi on veut dire dans les
tournois je vais pas dire dans un truc
rapide comme ça mais dans un tournoi en
longue tu vois genre sur cinq six jours
ça peut être marrant mais peut-on
experts de la position qui tu te prends
des notes et ironique callas est celle
de 7
je vois et je viens de recevoir une
notification joueur du grenier vient de
sortir une nouvelle vidéo je me tords ça
être regarder dès la fin du stream ça
même pendant votre nom laisse le stream
1 le joueur du grenier s'est vraiment
bien franchement je suis gros fan en
fait bon mais je crois que c'est à dire
plus c'est moi qui t'ai initiés non oui
c'était un spoiler active président la
prochaine fois qu'on doit vous
constaterez face d'ailleurs
ouais mais faudra que tu te fasses l2
guild of war est fantastique
la ville est génial ce mec
non non je ne joue pas le tournoi
je suis un spectateur spectateur avisé
chute partout je suis surtout les
tchatches partout
brad est en train de prendre le dessus
mais en fait deux finales sur pareil ça
commence à ressembler à une position
d'échec normal en fait ouais vraiment
tout moment l'auteure marié je pense pas
à mon cou en soi mais pourquoi pierre
bataille très classe s'adresse les gens
parce qu'en plus moi je pense
intéressant c'est pas pour sauver des
flammes il pour pour progresser je
t'avais dit il pas à lydie recours
collectif en fait c'est mieux c'est plus
compréhensible bon bizarrement t'appeler
equi 93 qui disent que je peux encore
main trianon et le tournoi a fortiori a
déjà commencé une fois donc demain tu
pars à 6 heures on porte pas 6h13 chopin
prem's je suis joue pour le
rapprochement cette idiotie peut-être
c'est juste pour te dis pas cher je suis
sûr c'est ça aucune explication quoi
français mais bon ça va tu vas arriver
pas trop tard à paris tu vas pouvoir
dormir la journée non ouais bah tu vois
du poids paris quand je disais je suis
ce que je suis chez moi donc calé chez
quelqu'un qui connaît vraiment la cote
en fait merci je me couche pas ça ne
fait pas trop normalement pour faire
dormir dans mon lit et puis quand je
viens je suis bonne compagnie papa juge
je viens dit je te prends ton pas faire
qualifier cette d'ailleurs menacé qu'il
éprouve 8 sur rydzek plus que yossi
sarid zèle toi tu as voulu préparer part
d'un e3
je veux faire du grand jeu qui est quand
même six mois
mais du coup à demain demain se vident
leur machin c'est pas mal létourneau ce
carrosse a commencé à quelle heure ces
genres dimanche matin dans son essai
samedi matin mais était content d'aller
jouer où j'aurai au bout d'un moment tu
es un peu c'est pas un peu usé la de
repartir en tournoi machin tu arrêtes tu
aurais pas plutôt rester chez soi
franchement non je crois avoir fait pour
la suite mais autant de tournois en fait
non je sais pas en fait sur le coup je
résiste pas tu vois je suis à la danse
je planifie je planifie prépare une
potion pour autant démunie voie puisque
je vais là ça va j'ai pas trop de temps
jeu kg ça c'est un saint vith samedi au
pire avant et après aux québécois c'est
marrant fin c'est rien c'est maroc ça
projet tournoi sans décembre à prêter un
peu tranquille après talent australie
nouvelle zélande ça va être sympa c'est
de faire des petits reportages de là bas
ce sera vraiment cool du bout du monde
très sympa ça on sera sur la chaîne 10
rim en janvier en exclusivité quelque
part on peut lire ouais je sais comment
les américains appellent l'australie
genre en bas et en dessous user même
qu'est en train de craquer face à celle
de 7 c'est une belle partie d'user name
amy tu vas forte à faire dans ce tournoi
parce que tu vas voir un adversaire de
taille
ninja qui a gagné autant bien thouars là
de la deuxième ronde laval va très
bientôt débuter
il emmène va tomber voilà ce qui est
chose faite et hockey
as-tu contre baptistère jardin les
scores tu veux que je fasse un petit
point score en ligue europa a tendance à
rejoindre
alors nous on mène 1-0 à apollon way
from the wild hunt qui mal d'atouts
comme d'hab l'atalante a gagné 3 0
contre everton à domicile l'austria
vienne prend 5 1 à domicile contre le
milan ac 10 nano qui a vu l'équipe de
vlad gagne 3 1 contre
skender b ou cantonal l'écho motifs 0 0
hoffenheim braga driving under là avec à
athènes mène 2-1 rijeka prague mène 1-0
contre le maccabi tel aviv
villarreal 3-1 contre astana n'ayant
boys un groupe de partisans
eysines 0-0 contre le sheriff tiraspol
mais c'est quoi ces équipes n'ont
maintenant rien je comprends pas c'est
quoi la ligue europa en fait c'est celle
des amis non mais c'est le festival des
noms à charlie chérif dall young boys
boys de berne
oui mais bon enfin sont très connus mais
je sais je connais on est effaré
presqu'aucune les apollons enfin je sais
pas ça va quoi faire enfin c'est une
compétition officielle
enfin je me demande si ça le jour aux
échecs m je pense que enfin plata
l'arabica il votre nom n'est pas
homologué du dégage la compétition ça
pour nous mais c'est pas une grosse cote
vers le bas score après je connais pas
votre avis sur le chat 1 et voilà lario
voilà qui va d'ailleurs et le tour down
under en cyclisme bien joué bien vu
atalay qui aimerait bien pouvoir
comprendre ce qu'on dit il sent que
c'est intéressant même sens comprendre
tu vois il se dit houle a eu les sondés
sort de ré le soupçonne de leur bouche
sont 33 cents
nathalie bernard masset calello tueur en
vrai kevin 22 82 bon c'est un peu arrêt
l'eau non moi je suis content enfin je
suis content en fait c'est quand j'ai
recommencé à jouer je pensais que
j'allais perdre plein de points en fait
non je sais pas pourquoi en faites pas
ce que je ressens d'être super nul enfin
tu vas les rockets ouais on oublie
peut-être tenté une ruine dans la
prochaine
la mauvaise c'est trop de pression en
échec par man a lui aussi levé du rock'n
te tient droit turc d'accueil droit de
dire ce soir il ya un match de pro d2
quoi vannes contre contre bayonne voilà
des bons matches gagnés à bayonne est un
sage ou 3 0 pour bayonne ou pénalité à
la 2e minute ut15 qu'est ce que c'est
que ça 10 à nice 1 à la pro d2 ça va
être la guerre cette année ça va être
très très chaud tata les perpignanais
ils sont là ils sont très très chaud tu
à colomiers est à montauban pas le stade
montois tu as bayonne
ça sent le rugby tu as les biarrots
talent et dacquois l'espèce de laurent
offre ici laurent frayssinet de dax
laurent ne boxent 1 de la laurent et il
en milieu de tableau
tu as béziers ça sent le rugby ça c'est
800 de rugby tu as carcassonne et
narbonne dans les dents liés dans les
villes qui semble vraiment le rugby de
terroir dans le sud est là le suédois
est ce plutôt sa part le rugby même
veulent se fout de notre gueule comme
sérieux ils continuent à se moquer de
nous sur skype ah non il me dit me tue
le lavaur dise quoi il fasse en fait
qu'entre d'être météo si on fait un peu
pâle attention parce que quand tu
craques tendent à jouer enfin non mais
quand il gagne le set je sais pas quoi
et donc il a fait une petite ville oui
droit je suis j'ai trouvé qu'il
prendrait sa trachée du corps mais en
fait juste y accueille cette main tendue
j'espère que le troll club il va à nyon
c'est ça mais en fait ils ont transmis
ouais mais un ajout en direct ou
transmis
matra va donc voilà c'est le beau jeu on
accepte non là où ça craint vice et si
on fait ce genre de chose ont des vidéos
qu'on prépare mélangez pas un bon mal au
foot mètres qui passe une fois sur un
live là il 3 litres hall mais bon on
l'entend pas trop on entend pas trop la
nouvelle fantastique van houtte rôle est
tout le temps en fait c'est horrible
c'est une bonne prépa pour jouer contre
mon gré de leurs doigts
je regarde live je cherche les conneries
qui dit pour les trolls et sur internet
en tout temps mais j'ai pas lui il peut
mais elles veulent ça peut le faire rire
la voix de vlad essaie de chauffe et cie
comprend le vit ça peut le faire marrer
ces dix années
mais quand tu dépasses ennemis 3-1
automation m vidéo il faut le demander
tu as des gens comprennent que donc on
attend
je vois ça y comprennent pas en fait
merci
votre du parlant mais à temps parce que
ça marchait pas
à
je touche tous les bugs là tant pis tant
qu'ils ne sont donc pas encore gagné
ouais
qu'est ce que tu as joué avec les
blockbusters la saison prochaine
normalement oui on verra ça toi toi
cloud de stars 2-3 qu'est ce que c'est
que ça je passe des ventes au québec et
henri que je me la jouer quoi
alors là c'était la deuxième partie
c'était la seconde partie exactement
je suis de retour
alors ce qu'on met une autre partie tu
va regarder on va regarder à rio
justement lario où il en est c'est pas
si clair la partie dario je pense qu'il
va gagner et non quoique c'est compliqué
et ça joue pas mal et du niveau que la
tenue du bitstream si bien je suis fier
d'eux
je sais pas c'est gagnant pour un pur à
rio ou pas difficile à juger ses
positions toujours avec les pions passé
de côté c'est peut-être nul
tu vois un mail en fait ouais mais le
reste suivant un truc
moi je viens de dire ouais mais il va
perdre en fait c'est tout simple vous
savez ça valait quelle couleur est ça va
a perdu incroyable
un peu marre en fait on truque des
jantes on serait content en fait ouais
j'ai un truc en plus celui-ci pas bachar
beaucoup ça donne oui c'est un
journaliste alors nouvelle position park
où commence dit ça mais massa qui a
souffert tiens tu joues contre halo
zaurus alors attention aussi avec les
classes ans que ces déclassements 960
pas vraiment moi je suis 2677 je vais
jouer cinq partis dont on peut voir des
maxi qui sont mal classés qui joue
beaucoup mieux qu eux enfin tu vois ce
que je veux dire ça le classement ne
veut absolument rien dire dans ce souk
tlata plessé d'art juste une partie dans
ta vie de ce truc là et puis tu vois
alors tu prends le centre bon dessert
1 française de rigueur mais c'est une
française d'une bonne période pour toi
parce que tu vas y a pas de ça il n'y a
pas de ces cinq mais bon après le but
les pensées du coup d'ailleurs il dit
dario h7 direct très taquin
juste ma femme qui est un petit peu
malade c'est pour ça je donne conseil de
quoi faire que de loire en grogne
inverse boivent de l'eau et se repose
alors marié qui va faire le sous-marin
ans tombe à remonter souvent joue quoi
du pouce son pion vers f5
on y va quand il peut encore dire ok
grand requin tout le monde de toutes
sortes d'affaires f5 et pousser à fond
soit ça soit je ne sais pas quelle est
la première pièce d'un machin il me
saoule qu'on améliore tes pièces
voilà où continuent de suivre dès 15h
vous savez à quoi ça fait référence
failli lawson marine en fait j'en ai
entendu puis je les subis mais j'ai
oublié de dire des trucs que tu as tu
sais que tu as déjà entendu et puis j'ai
pu du coup ce que c'est en fait une
chanson we know message est compris
ou alors le club de foot de villarreal
mais une raison en fait j'avais vu ce
que c'est
maintenant un gros avantage d'espacé
tout eh bien tu vas pas faire du tourin
peut-être face tour à 8 lui en fait tu
es petit rock du sony ça c'est
intéressant en fait vous faire un peu
optimiste à canon
sa mère ne pas regarder jouer hyper
tempo sais pas si c'était ok je pense
pas que ce soit si grave
je veux pas dire de conneries je pense
que ça va bah ouais ouais
je veux pas spoiler en fait fin pas
fumer je pars tu peux te dire quelle
idée de fabien ce dont parlait c'était
fou prend ses cinq français 5 et dame
prend 1,5
mais bon pas sûr que c'était bon parce
que dans ce cas ça aurait pas mal le roi
il ya fait tour à 8 ce qui est pas mal
contre la colonne à seule colonne verte
sur l'échiquier pour le moment alors que
ce soit
il faut deux tu m'as sauvé cinq super
toit après ouais ou la route dont
essayons d'aller mater fouet sur un roi
d'ithaque arriver cette matière je suis
là pas rater non je suis là par une
belle victoire belle victoire alors on
va les voir 7 de baisse qui rigolaient
de dario de talent à voir un peu ce que
ça donne mort ou sont en heures sup
on aimerait bien rester crime non et
nous devons tourner en heures sup
presque
ce normal le pilote a dit chan
on n'est pas couché gaspacho gaspacho
neige afin de manger du gaspacho serait
pas faim tu vas petite soupe quoi ouais
ouais
nodl soupe c'est pas mal 9' souvent
réussir à le faire
l'ue signe de ce calme et lucide de ska
vie et plusieurs versions je crois à
rioz sur cette chanson choix que c'était
aussi un dessin de la fidh je sais plus
qui lussi in the sky
alors cette de sède n'est pas partie ce
manque trop de addario parce que j'ai un
son qui est en train de se faire train
se faire prendre dans le combat d'avants
pendant essai
donc où on n'a rien de cette partie je
n'entends plus parler là hors jeu
le truc c'est que moi je ne suis pas
trop ce que tu regardes comme j'ai pas
le parcours se défend non en fait je
crois qu'on a fait juste trop de vidéos
aujourd'hui là je pense enfin fait
parler gaga nous a mis un message sur
youtube et dire qu'au lycée on a encore
qui ose dire que les échecs c'est
ennuyeux après matt live d'aujourd'hui
bat m enfin sa commande edwards et de
manière marrante en fait
mais dès que tu commandes de marantz à
des gens qui pensaient d'écart sur les
forums pour dire dans les trucs
officielle où il ce n'est pas commentée
comme un cours d'échecs
c'est pas bien quoi c'est pas bien ce
n'est pas un cours d mais je préfère
clairement porter un commentaire de
j'apprends des choses quoi mondiale
comptage de foot fait que crier ce n'est
pas intéressant bord du monde sur la
table c'est que ça quand tu regardes les
matchs de vous qui doivent eux mêmes
quand ils vont voir des films je veux
voir que des documentaires
quel est ce nouveau film avec tom cruise
quoi je n'apprends absolument rien mon
fusil quoi je voulais regarder animal
planet beaucoup plus intéressant les
siens et retours fall mam et le pour le
coup aurait trop comprendre un truc
c'est que c'est très différent ce qui
donne un cours aussi tu commentes perdre
face à la roja la cour ne s'est pas
fléchir j'explique des principes quand
on sait les master class accords
collectifs etc
mais la cdu commentaire en faites vous
faire vivre le truc que ce pass pass 1
8e de finale de coupe du monde
c'est un joueur qu'on aime bien et les
rebondissements enfin chez moi si c'est
juste par une variante dire que cette
ati d'attaché pas au cahier des joueurs
peut-être à ses phares qui va être très
content il va prendre des trucs des
autres on va les perdre les joueurs un
peu appel initié à monbahus déjà il vaut
ne pas les cornes des vaches et pas
comprendre que si tu veux
mon petit jeu d'échecs savane une parti
pris c'est ça c'est d'animer mais quand
on parle d'échec on en parle
sérieusement qu'on nous parle de la
région tentés de notre mieux pour
expliquer et de l'aider bonne ligne mais
comme n'est pas là pour être prêt de
chiant marne est illégal la presse y en
a qui aiment saba continue enfin en
allons vous empêche pas de faire en fait
mais je n'ai pas critiqué pas on ne
critique pas ceux qui font sans fenêtre
n'est pas là nous a créé un forum à dire
non aux voyageurs pas non c'est pas ça
s'est passé je voulais juste dire ça
mais en fait mais en fait du coup sur
les vidéos qu'on fait à en différer en
fait on réalise plutôt très bien en
général mais croyant digérer sait déjà
c'est différent parce que avoir vérifié
machin analysé ouais on a pas il s'est
passé des relations se trouve on
retourne l'arrivée d'ailleurs plusieurs
fois
alors oui très content de la défaite de
cette baisse très très heureux tu as
perdu tu dégages
bon pour le moment toi tu tiens tu tires
la tête du tournoi met à égalité avec
crypte et de chasse 30
c'est chaud c'est un mauvais
départageant plus on en est pas encore
là
déjà pu marquer des points dès puntos
des points
ça devrait s'il n'a pas compris les
règles niveau des rocs l'imaginent
d'ailleurs contre crypte
derrière le pseudo en fait tout
qu'est ce que c'est
car il y avait 2 tours 17 tu vas faire
grand roque en fait doubler direct
alors ta b 6 tasses et si ce qui va
arriver ta grande banque n'a oublié
l'invasion
j'aime bien son fiancé tôt en fait
telio ça le fait marrer aussi crypte
s'est dit que ça fait un peu catacombes
je trouve ça existe resterai superman
con ou dans ce chef la tripartite et aux
niches plus quoi [ __ ] au point d'un
autre âge quoi déjà dépassé complètement
dépassés
tamango ski j'ai toujours un projet dans
mon tiroir pour alger les échecs à notre
site on en parlera sûrement sérieusement
un jour prochain
ok mais parce qu'il a fait pas mal de
retransmission et tout et c'est vrai que
les systèmes de mort vous sépare des
bonnes des bonnes caméras et du beau du
bon matériel en fait mais du bon son il
beaucoup plus beaucoup plus
professionnelle que ce qu'on a
habituellement
on a tout d'un coup tu commences à te
reprendre du poil de la bête
les pièces sortent pour que le bout de
langue était très content avec son épée
et modérateur de moder en fait je lis
pas tous les tchats tu vas j'étais plus
sur le chat tweet tweet pas de pas mal
de choses melior en fait quand à 3 chat
en même temps où donner de la tête la
tata picot qui est le foot était
rayonnant wifi qu'il ferait ce qu'il
peut plus tard chaque chose en son temps
c'est james agadir
peut-être que tu vas devoir à gaillard
james cities a mis sa bouille coûte 9
chaque grille fer qui avait 5 et 6 3 le
code plus tard potvin je voulais
empêcher fouache 3
non mais t'es bien là ouais ça va ça va
bon ben on y va le petit bonus ces 4 x 3
ans et ça ça avec le fou sorti de nulle
part en fait à la fougue et la donne
le fameux le fou d'outre-tombe j'irai
bon d'avoir un truc marrant je leur à 4
c3 et la dame aurait davantage et c'est
parti bon c'est pas sûr que le meilleur
coin c'est juste marrant d'aller au ps
guy le placement des pièces au début
était bizarre qu'on dirait que c'est pas
très conventionnel
effectivement
j'espère que tu hésites avec un truc
complètement idiot là j'ai attaqué à
trois mais je suis restée à carrière
achetée sur ce qui doit y penser mais à
s'assumer de fourbes et quatre balles il
y va voilà je dis c'est là selon la
colonne à nantes il peut peut-être plus
jamais réutilisé sa tour et saddam et
tous ces horribles tu as peut être
bloquée trois pieds de pièces là c'est
marrant ça
même sacrément les échecs 960 les
nouveaux concepts séculaire des choses
assez belle comme ça mais c'est pas
nouveau en fait dans les mains on
connaît ce concept-là gens s'arrêtent
dans les espagnols et où cette idée mais
en fait c'est plus facile à réaliser en
en 960 ce que tu pars pas d'une position
connue en fait donc tu peux vraiment le
faire sur la culture générale tu vois ce
que je veux dire quand et bien là c'est
dur ça bouge pas trop le banc la préf
aux finiens
c'est toujours d'un ministre non mais là
c'est bon de faire sa large au lycée
d'ameuter plus du projet après tours f1
je vais faire un match du pouvoir
mais en fait à l'équivalent de windham
et d'une tour contre un fou c'est
vraiment joli j'ai passé jean chatte a
apprécié le blocage la colonna
même par wade ainsi adam des deux matchs
les grottes interdit les toits déjà
bougé non gironde des deux maîtres sympa
ouais parti de pas mal je crois que
c'est très très fier de toi ça soit
c'est qu'ils se barrent chez soi c'est
qui ce bas fonds c'est très joli
moi ça m'a plu en tout cas on attend
déjà un peu de beauté comme ça je vais
regarder ce qu'on approche des risques
en fait on approche de plus en plus des
6000 abonnés en fait c'est
impressionnant dans les apple non autre
chose n'est pas mis en fait d'habitude
on est là il ya genre 20 25 nouveaux
abonnés et loris a fait 45 puisque c'est
mvl puisque machin mais là la whey là du
coup peut-être 1986 en fait c'est 1980
quand on arrêtait le stream mais j'ai
réussi nouveau en fête ok donc demain
peut-être barret demain ou au pire ce
week-end normalement pression je prends
un nouveau devis nouveau championne
comme bonjour sympa mais on les a pas vu
il m'a en fait c'est se tient la
hyéroise 5 et le roi part de l'autre
côté c'est fini la partie de chasse
wesley si le roi se barre par ici ça
devrait aller jean roy des six mètres
reprend v6 pourtant perd on apprend mais
ça va pas suffire genre juste trois
points f4 et tour des 5 et protégé après
on file prendre le pion beaucoup c'est
cool parce que ça je connais pas même
les nerfs des gens de passer les petits
projets tout ça non mais en fait je
connais marc vous
je connais la personne en fait c'est un
mec très très sympa et on a parlé il ya
un moment on a des petites on ad on a
des petites idées en fait mais je n'en
ai jamais parlé ce que c'était avant que
tu interviennent sur la chaîne tout ça
ces choses qui sont complètement
antérieure à toi en fait bon massage
polonophobes mais je vais aimer la
question à quel âge as tu appris écrit
cela
enfin gérer le duel tu voudras l'autre
titre et du tournoi are you quand je
compose une pustule non il serait très
heureux de faire une petite news -
bonjour
la rue libye paraît que qu'elle veut
plus jouer avec toi en de ga'hoole c'est
tout à fait vrai c'est complètement nul
quoi c'est horrible en fait je te jouer
à cariou d'hergé juger par les corses
qui m'avait fait à rully may cry
meatyard quand tu veux on est 2e avec un
pote on vous prend avec libye en vie de
sakharov un bug house ben ali mais il
apprend que moi je vais qui comptait
deux bons nuls bull vie au fait si on
peut faire une équipe ensemble mais je
ne veux pas jouer à il fallait bien
faire ça la veille ccc ccc là qu'il me
faudrait nouvelle en fait je pense qu'il
est pas mal aux bagues house
je crois qu'il joue bien je crois que si
on joue je pense qu'il peut nous prendre
en simultané aux bagarres tous en fête
mais déjà trois échecs ce n'était pas
fameux
on verra c'est juste les commentaires
trois échecs et pendant que je vote soit
ça soit tu joues le truc calcul après
différents styles et maybe de sa cache
pas que c'est vraiment pas pour toi
non vous avez je déteste
non mais tu vas à rio ils haïssent est
pris aux goudes et on habite free en
fait ça lui plaît quoi trouble très
important nous à jeudi soir d'ailleurs
demain il est tombé à 1 bis stream
discorde
j'avais ça les ccc une plateforme rien
notoires du vieux dit kéké qui devient
de plus en plus fort en cette soirée du
jeudi se disent à nice 1
146 spectateurs à l'imec sont là ils
sont très heureux si on pouvait faire
une grande boum avec toutes les tous les
abonnés avec ses chercheuses et un truc
avec tous les abonnés aux folles enfin
la contrefaçon de ses quatre sur paris
le big three meeting le bitstream ton à
la partie importante pour toi parce que
classement bonté seul en tête mais il ya
beaucoup de mecs à 3 ils sont sept à
trois derrière ça pousse quoi madame r
qui en pls il a zéro sur 14 qui joue pas
mal mais apparemment les jardins font 60
salat à seix il y en a marqué son
premier point sur cinq il était mal et
on sait pas évitant les 960 quand t'as
pas l'habitude c'est un peu spécial
on ne sait jamais libre dames en brousse
qui est de retour en parler toi mort
vous parle ce n'est pas la tuer dans
l'oeuf ou de cases noires mais je vais
pas dire que c'est comme une structure
solide jeu pas sur ton fuzhou vraiment
mieux que l'autre en fait bonne nouvelle
ce recueil en d4 1 jour
ou pas
pour faire annuler sa lettre hanter la
gagne dans la prochaine après un jeu
c'est cette peur il accepte seulement
foule de cadeaux autour note
je veux que pour jouer quoi tu es en
train de dire de meurtre et
condescendante que comme tu l'as déjà
gagné je t'en fous tu gagnes des mois
c'est ce que tu es en train de dire que
ton palmarès est telle que le taux arabi
serait en fait non mais je vais essayer
de comprendre la table le sens de ta
dernière phrase je me fous gagner le
tournoi le plus prestigieux de l'année
coiffant fin du mois et enfin faire un
tournoi annuel bitstream je pense à un
moment donné tu as genre le tournoi de
l'année
si tu le gagnes quelque part tu vois ce
que le dire tu l'yonne tout cru par
était au dessus
barrymore grisonnants on parlait un peu
du fait que ouais tu parlais de ces
projets on en a déjà parlé ensemble hier
un petit moment et tout ça et que tu
étais vraiment un ancien de la chaîne
glisse rim pa ta merde quand je les
rockets en fait mais tu as déjà bouger
ton roi je crois mais non les deux cas
c'est mon couple là je perds pas acquis
a pas un truc je reprends son coût koala
jamais vraiment c'est pas toujours
broncos abandonne chargé pas mais tu as
passé je sais pas comment ça marche moi
je ne comprends pas à quoi bon c'est mon
stick
non en fait il faut toucher la tour en
fait ta ta ta du juste avait surgi en
fait t'es pas allé jusqu'à la tour avec
le roi banon mais je mangeais je ne sais
pas je rêvais bon sinon on fait quand il
dit qu'il fallait d'ailleurs st je m'en
fous moi c'est que je peux jamais le
jour à jeun
c'est toujours le droit de s'interroger
critique toujours coton ou encore un
nouveau truc qui sait pas ce qui peut
pas m'arriver on joue aux échecs réel on
the rocks et du retour à 8 je bouge
madame d'emprunt pour preuve un jeu
parfait trop épique
c'était trop épique comme fin de partie
j'ai pas qu'on me sentais bien au rail
games et où tu es pas faire du tout et
je vous aiderai parti et là hop poule
aux oeufs d'or en juin dégage feu
d'engin le truc qui ne peut le savoir
très moral ces passages aura un coup
légal de rock et c'est pas georges
propos valleroy la toile
c'est juste je sais pas bref il faut
tout faire et tout en fait non mais
c'était marrant
là ils vont enfin gers et j'aimerais
bien quand tu payes stream qui est ces
petits moments un peu watts de fac tu
vois c'est ça qui me fait marrer ça je
m'y attendais pas su je trouve ça un peu
drôle à temps et c'est de mettre des
gens qu'on n'a jamais vu alors tiens
royal pays chess montrera le garde a
réussi moi j'ai bien aimé ça fait marrer
c'était marrant c'est pour des moments
comme ça que les gens regardent la bonne
humeur meurs meurs meurs du coup depuis
je me suis remis à coude les chansons de
la chanson de dimanche
ouais c'était drôle pas la grande
musique mais je sais que mon petit truc
j'attends vraiment cam latin le film
j'en peux plus entre game of thrones est
qu'à me le suis en paix elle est ce
qu'il faut on en a gros tu avais vu
l'épisode avec attila totalement rock et
moi je suis beaucoup moins experts que
toi j'ai fait chauffer les épisodes par
ci par là mais j'ai déjà pas tout vu il
m'a pas du tout convaincu at il assez
fantastique quoi ils y ont veut tout
votre heure sinon brûle tout mais bon
fao
si on donne tout notre or bas on pourra
plus payer quoi il soit on suit est un
nomade donc l on t'a pas trop de frais
mais bon nos vies dans la pierre on a
des employés on peut pas les e-bonds tu
veux la moitié de notre nom enfin jean
après lyon veut toutes vos femmes
bah ouais bah non pas l'église sinon je
brûle tout bail on brûle mais non on
veut comme en saison mais c'est
fantastique
d'après il veut quelque chose de typique
oui bah je sais pas quoi
d'ailleurs on veut plus on va dit
dernière
si si lui donne il utilise un truc de
typique fait disjoncter d'un truc
typîque
bon bah du l'apport au miel mais les
cuisines sont fermées donc ça va être
froid quoi bas et non ils vont pas si
hockey quoi je prends quoi la peau miel
sinon je brûle tout il lui donne un tipi
en fait entre le mec menacé de fermer sa
chaîne sears rappelle typique de sixt
cet épisode fait l'écho conférence des
oui bien sûr et oui je vois la base ça
me dit je suis quand même content de ce
huit oscars ou quoi la virtu à sa
patronne
non non vous esquissez la viande de cerf
avec du miel c'est pas du lapin ces
données - les femmes on peut pas sinon
je brûle tout bas on peut pas corriger
pas donné moix qui veut qu'ils yeux
donnez-moi toutes vos étoffes et puis
bon là les mecs se regarder puis un
troisième du bas nous enfin les étoffes
c'est quand même d'être elle c'est à
mario carrier c'est tellement bon
camelot la suite au ciné bientôt à cette
fantastique est allé bd aussi qu'à blood
alors je passe vous êtes octobre l'armée
camelot c'est fantastique ce soit alors
ça est la dernière ronde elle le linge
le linge de maison c'est ça et qui dit
linge de maison
ça fait longtemps que j'ai pu les
épisodes les connaissez par coeur mais
bon les meilleurs épisodes savais que ça
va être karadoc et perceval bout si l'on
s'y arrête
quand ils prennent un parchemin ou faire
une boule de feu tabac eu cet épisode et
de débiles karadoc et perceval il brille
unis prennent un parchemin faire des
boules de feu il le lisant sortant quoi
ils sont complètement à la rue ce
pronostic
bayod fin non vous n'avez pas ni de
pâlir en sortant enfin donc on ne fait
pas ce mois le préféré de mangou c'est à
tarte aux myrtilles et fantastique pour
colmater les brèches pour colmater les
murs notre côté je n'ai pas dit c'est
une tarte aux myrtilles
c'était pas évident de devinez quoi
fantastique
enfin
les gens sont partis ce tribun en vue et
qui démarque non en espagnol si
l'espagne a poli il serait presque à
rêver sur scène avec adorait ses marques
y arriverez scarla paris nice à aux
sites ou qui révèle vidéo en espagnol je
me passe avec mon espagnol de francs
enfin je lis qu'ils écrivent en fait que
ça veut dire s'ils tombent donne quoi
nimbus apte à passer pas mal de temps en
espagne machin tu parle pas du tout non
je doute moi je connais un petit réchaud
et opportuniste il ya des gens ici à des
gens qui parlent portugais j'aime bien
ce que savoir ce que veut dire et peace
hall en portugais brésilien
c'est donc lorgeoux et puis ça parce
qu'en fait je regarde le streamer chase
points comme je kiffe le streamer 16
points comme portugais est fantastique
edison est sûr que des vidéos des fois
je regarde s'escrimant portugais j'aime
beaucoup en fait c'est un cri corps
krikor en fait ouais parce que j'ai joué
à starcraft non en italien chez pas
et je passais à des portugais
ce que tim blitz rima des portugais
c'est un peu la question qu'on se pose
tout le monde se pose
tintin tintin j'imagine même pas comment
vlad et en pls aujourd'hui le pont c'est
que ça c'est encore le droit de faire un
grand roc ou pas voilà je peux toujours
aller soit tu sais non non je ne veux
pas y aller mais ceux ci avaient un slip
noms dont j'ai fait un petit rancourt
faut pas se tromper comme ça c'est vrai
quoi
voilà une transgreen à côté de l'autre
je veux pas me trouve de quoi les grog
c'était dans les plans thabeet rick 2008
27 me qui dit on sera dos au blitz
oscars aux fab clin d'oeil à il ya le
blitz oscaro c'est le meilleur bilan du
week-end en français reçoit sur les
beats oscars au meilleur rythme de leur
vie en france plus court ou tu t'en
circuit corse n'en restait 1960 ce soir
c'est du cousu main on regarde le
classement un peu ce qui se passe je
veux aller voir la partie dario puisque
ça joue il joue contre 7 de baisse sa
chambre et de thaler en fait la bonne
nouvelle pour grèce excèdent de beast
est gagnant b ben je suis pas et d'un
moins bon des partages que toi la 4 sur
5 milliards mon départ sache que toi bon
ok ballon mais bon c'est quand même le
touran l'année avec ton travail une
premier tour f sur 70 stream cher c'est
un truc ça tue la fiche tulle affiche
dans sa chambre après maison j'ai fait 3
960 la merde juste
normal quand on est pas mal
en fait à rio a perdu à cause de la v
avec la même que tu vois quoi je vais
faire grogner droit salades et des
troncs à jenny ça quand même
on est pas mal pas mal non plus si on en
a gros du 960 de bikini à une meuf qui
stream sur lynch est espionnage pas
cette heure là des lunes
c'est pas parce que tu marches
professional non passionna orlova
canadienne très qualifiés
je suis pas bien mais c'est pas vous
abonner aussi à la chaîne switcher sur
laquelle on stream balance avec on ne
dit pas tout le temps mais on est
parfois on oublie n'oublie très souvent
je rappellerai prochain rêve là la
chaîne youtube de tuer ce point comme
aussi
attends moi je suis un peu ce tournoi je
vais retourner voir là parce que votre
doigté pour la nulle en mai mais on la
seule à are you malheureusement il va
passer à la trappe
mais c'est aussi votre truc propose de
reprendre un coup c'est dommage oui je
n'ai pas de troupes dégage ontario
gagnera pas le tournoi c'est peut-être
cette zone
donc c'est le seul qui écrit couple et
ce qui varie faire un cloud slip dans
son tournoi en un an il a gagné au
parlement il est leader ça va être chaud
tu as aussi à les eaux russes qui peut
gagner tu avais battu malheur partout
qui jouent contre crypte mais je pense
que crypte va gagner grâce et hyper
compliqué composition c'est chaud mais
je sens bien un script c'est pas mal de
demandes d'amitié sur chaque point comme
qui arrive ça me fait des petits
ces gens qui veulent devenir amis ont
accepté j'accepte les amis tous les amis
j'accepte c'était sablic ça il accepte
tous les risques inhérents va perdre en
fait tu as encore ta chance si tu gagnes
tu peux encore gagner cette baisse il
faut que tu fasses nul hein mais un
objectif menuires tenir exactement c'est
chaud elle monta qualité de moins mais
tagro c'est tagro contre je n'aime pas
ce qu'en fait son adversaire gagne les
adversaires un moins bon des partages
donc mettre cette z et forcément contre
toi en fait
bon ok on passe à un truc glorieux je
sais que ça allait faire orifices des
regrets mais bon tu es obligé de la
pendule as tu peux pas faire autrement
une trucs pas très glorieux venir ouais
mais bon est-ce que tu as le choix je
pense qu'il peut abandonner un c'est
injouable ça non mais enfin pourquoi tu
frais nul en fait rage il faut jouer
plus vite
c'est aussi le blitz un fab tu fais un
petit coup de tourbe et ont bien senti
non tu as gagné tu repasses à nantes et
égalité et égalité avec celle de seb
même des partages pour le moment on
partage
il va faire attendre la dernière partie
correspond non mais encore un mec est en
train de jouer je ne sais pas avec le
départage ça va influencer
vous êtes à égalité parfaite à égalité
parfaite de deux médailles d'or vous
êtes de vainqueur du tour n'a en fait
pas au sol qu'est ce que je veux dire
écoutez moi ce sont ces satanés truc moi
je vais y aller un petit pourra donner
encore quoi bonsoir femmes en ici j'y
vais tout de suite donc c'est pas pour
autant mes lignes vides demain le train
à 6 heures du mat
mais bon maintenant pas chaud pour le
pour les oscars ou de maintenant demain
on fera une vidéo soit parti de vie de
l'air mais c'est pas promis non plus et
samedi pareil mais on sera là en live
dimanche il ya les départage donc bonne
soirée tout le monde allait bientôt un
an